Here's one way to prove it to yourself that you drop the fraction instead of
rounding. Try computing the texel location using U V's for a 1 by 1 texture. A
texture with 1 texel. You know in advance the answer you always want for the
texture coordinate is the integer 0. A texture coordinate of 0.72 multiplied by
1 will have its fraction dropped, and you'll get 0. As will every other texel
coordinate. If you round instead, you would get the wrong answer of 1. I like
testing with simple cases like this. If the formula doesn't work for a single
pixel conversion, we can't expect it will work for larger textures. It's
interesting to note that the upper right hand corner of the texel, which has UV
of 1.0, 1.0. Would when multiplied by the texture resolution of 16 by 16, then
have texel coordinates of 16.0, 16.0, a texel that doesn't exist. In practical
terms, this doesn't matter as the value 15.99999 repeating is the same value as
16.0. So, there is a valid texel and a valid texel location to sample.